hay dos correcciones que quiero hacerle
al vídeo de la bomba de sodio potasio
una muy pequeña y no creo que te haya
hecho mucho ruido fue cerca del final
del vídeo como aprendimos anteriormente
tenemos al potasio siendo bombeado hacia
dentro de la célula por la bomba sodio
potasio déjame dibujar la membrana de
hecho dibujarla será útil para la
corrección más significativa que haré
después dibujamos a la membrana celular
déjame representar una sección
transversal de una membrana celular y
dibujamos la bomba sodio potasio justo
aquí vemos que bombea hacia afuera 3
iones de sodio por cada 2 iones de
potasio que bombea hacia adentro
definitivamente no se ve así pero nos da
una idea estamos bombeando iones de
potasio hacia adentro así que tenemos
camas
y acá más y estamos bombeando iones de
sodio hacia afuera y ese fue el único
objetivo de este vídeo cuando esto
cambia de forma con atp bombea los iones
de sodio hacia afuera ahora la
corrección menos significativa que
quiero hacer y no creo que te haya
confundido tanto es que casi al final de
ese vídeo dibujé los guiones de potasio
y dibuje una camas pero algunas veces
cerca del final de ese vídeo me refería
a ellos como iones de sodio y no quiero
que eso los confunda son los iones de
potasio los que están siendo bombeados
hacia adentro 2.000.000 de potasio son
bombeados hacia adentro por cada 3 iones
de sodio que son bombeados hacia afuera
no quiero aunque haya dibujado camas
algunas veces dije sodio accidentalmente
no quiero que eso te confunda ese es el
error menor el error más significativo
es que dije que la razón principal de
que tuvimos esta diferencia de potencial
el por qué es
en el exterior que en el interior así
que esto es
no os
x
sí
dije que la razón principal fue debido a
la proporción estamos bombeando hacia
fuera 3 iones de sodio por cada dos
iones de potasio que son bombeados al
interior y acabamos de recibir una carta
bastante buena de un profesor de
fisiología steven taylor en la
universidad de pensilvania él escribió
un correo muy interesante y me corrigió
es muy interesante pensar en eso en
general esto es lo que escribió y
analicemos lo que está diciendo dice
aquí en la escuela de medicina de la
universidad de pensilvania tenemos un
buen programa de simulación para la
enseñanza de los flujos de iones a
través de células genéricas
así que el flujo de iones es solo el
movimiento de los iones a través de la
membrana incluye los flujos debidos a la
bomba sodio y potasio así como los que
ocurren en la membrana debido a las
permeabilidad es en reposo al sodio
potasio cloro etcétera así que las
permeabilidad es en reposo es que tan
fácil es para estos iones ir a través de
la membrana y hablaremos más de eso en
un segundo una de las opciones del
programa permite a los estudiantes
variar la stec yo me tríada de la bomba
de tres a dos así que cuando él habla de
cambiar la estéreo metría de la bomba de
3 a 2 sólo habla de cambiar las
proporciones así que la cambian de tres
por cada dos a dos por cada dos lo que
significa esto es ya tienen un programa
de simulación que dice
bien qué pasa si la bomba de sodio
potasio en lugar de bombear tres odios
hacia afuera por cada dos potasio que
bombea hacia adentro qué pasaría si
fueran iguales
pasaría si fueran dos odios y dos
potasio y pasado en mi explicación de
por qué tenemos esta diferencia de
potencial eso no debería de ocasionar
una diferencia de potencial si la razón
principal fuera el stec yo me tri a la
proporción del sodio siendo bombeado en
relación al potasio que es bombeado
hacia adentro pero continúa diciendo
podrían cambiarlo a dos por cada dos y
permitir observar qué pasa con el
potencial de la membrana esta maniobra
produce un cambio en el valor normal de
evm cercano a menos 80 mil volts y me
dieron eso tomaron el voltaje aquí menos
el voltaje de allá de tal manera que
obtenemos un número negativo esto es más
positivo es un número mayor
así que cambia de menos 80 mil volts
hasta menos 78 mil volts lo que él está
diciendo es que si cambias esto de 3 a
23 odios por cada 2 potasio que son
bombeados hacia adentro
acceso a todos por cada dos de hecho no
cambia el potencial tanto aún tienes un
ambiente más positivo afuera que adentro
y eso nos lleva a la pregunta entonces
por qué tenemos el potencial si la esté
yo metía de esa proporción no es la
causa principal así que dice que cambia
un poco la diferencia de potencial
disminuye un poco esta maniobra hinchar
la célula un ligero porcentaje y después
todo se estabiliza luego él continúa
escribiendo si bien es cierto que el
este geometría normal de la bomba tiene
una ligera influencia negativa en pm la
falta de balance en la éste -que yo me
tríada de la bomba no es la razón
principal del gran valor negativo bm de
la célula más bien la razón principal y
déjame subrayar esto más bien la razón
principal son los gradientes de
concentración que establece la bomba
concentración alta de potasio y baja de
sodio dentro de la célula baja de
potasio y alta de sodio fuera de ella
en combinación con que la membrana
celular en reposo es altamente permeable
al potasio y ligeramente permeable al
sodio dijimos en el último vídeo o en el
primer vídeo de la bomba sodio potasio
dijimos que había canales por los cuales
el sodio puede atravesar y también están
los canales por los que el potasio puede
atravesar y ahora lo que está diciendo
es que la causa principal de la
diferencia de potencial no es esta
proporción es el hecho de que la
membrana es altamente permeable al
potasio ésta es muy permeable el potasio
puede salir de ella si lo desea mucho
más fácil de lo que es para el sodio
entrar
lo que pasa aunque esto fuera una
proporción 2 a 2 esta es de hecho una de
3 a 2 pero aunque fuera una proporción
de 2 a 2 aunque este ambiente sea más
positivo es más probable que tengas
iones de potasio aquí abajo bombeados
hacia adentro en la manera adecuada para
atravesar y llegar al otro lado va en
contra del gradiente químico cierto
porque tienes una concentración mayor de
potasio aquí que acá es más probable que
tengas una bomba de potasio en la vía
correcta para atravesar este canal y
salir a que tengas un sodio yendo en la
dirección opuesta y eso es lo que genera
este ambiente tienes más potasio
saliendo debido a esta permeabilidad de
sodio entrando y esa es la causa
principal de la diferencia de potencial
entre el exterior y el interior así que
gracias a steve en vail or por esa
corrección muy interesante